merci madame rossignol la parole est un
monsieur daniel fasquelle
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre lors de
son élection en 2012 françois hollande
avait promis de se consacrer au
redressement productif du pays
l'industrie à lattes être une priorité
du quinquennat
qu'en est-il cinq ans après force est de
constater que le bilan est également sur
ce plan particulièrement désastreux
pourtant tous les indicateurs étaient au
vert prix du pétrole bas taux d'intérêt
proches de zéro euro relativement faible
mais alors que l'industrie représente
30% du pib en allemagne 24 % en italie
en france cette part est tombée à 19% et
nous avons perdu 170 emplois industriels
entre 2012 et 2016
sans compter les antillais glisse qui y
sont attachés
la raison ce fiasco la multiplication
des normes et règles nouvelles comme le
comte pénibilité et le matraquage fiscal
des entreprises et des consommateurs
mais je veux également dénoncé avec
force la bande ont répété deux fleurons
industriels avec une responsabilité
partagée entre françois hollande et son
fils spirituel
emmanuel macron ses amis c'est ainsi que
tous ensemble ils ont signé l'arrêt de
mort d'alstom énergie cédé à l'américain
general electric d'un secteur pourtant
stratégique dans lequel la france a
toujours été leader on nous promettait
la création de 1000 emplois
c'est 1000 emplois qui ont été ont été
supprimés que dire encore du rachat
d'alcatel lucent par le finlandais nokia
en 2015 ou encore du naufrage pour la
prison compte en mai 2016 de technique
par l'amérique à fmc une entreprise
française reprise par une entreprise
américaine qui ont été en difficulté
or à chaque nous aurions pu empêcher une
phrase résume tout elle a été prononcée
par emmanuel macron quand je
l'interpellé dans cet hémicycle sur la
nécessité pour le gouvernement français
de sauver my fair unique ex seafrance
dernière compagnie française transmanche
de transport de passagers on ne peut
rien faire alors ma question est simple
monsieur le ministre avez vous
conscience de votre responsabilité dans
cet abandon de plusieurs des plus beaux
fleurons de notre industrie française
depuis cinq ans si la parole est à
monsieur christian et caire
secret tarder et secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget et des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs il vous plaît monsieur le
député daniel fasquelle en matière de
pertes d'emplois industriels
la majorité précédente peut parler avec
paroles d'expert puisque ces sept cent
mille emplois industriels et ambiance
qui ont été perdus durant la précédente
législature
à l'heure où s'achève celle ci monsieur
le député je voudrais quand même vous
indiquez un certain nombre d'éléments au
cours de l'année 2016 ce sont cent
quatre-vingt-onze 1700 emplois qui ont
été créés dans le secteur marchand
cherchez donc entre 2007 et 2012 pareil
statistiques
vous parlez de secteur abandonné
monsieur le député je voudrais quand
même souligner l'attention du
gouvernement sur un certain nombre de
secteurs en difficulté je pense à la
filière nucléaire je pense à la filière
ferroviaire
ce gouvernement est mobilisé pour
soutenir les filières
il l'a prouvé notamment sur le dossier
alstom
il le prouvera sur d'autres dossiers je
pense notamment à la filière nucléaire
alors monsieur le député ce gouvernement
a permis de remettre la france
industrielle en marche par des mesures
que vous n'avez pas voté vous n'avez pas
voté le sur amortissements pour les
entreprises vous n'avez pas voté
l'extension du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi qui permet à la
france d'avoir un coût du travail
inférieure aujourd'hui à celui de
l'allemagne
alors plutôt que nous donner des leçons
ou variés mieux de vous en tenir à la
réalité
merci monsieur willy